Transcriptor: Amaranta Heredia Jaén
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Alberto Kornblihtt: los genes, la evolución y nosotros
Me gusta pensar a la biología
como la ciencia que se ocupa
de las similitudes y las diferencias
en el mundo vivo.
Por ejemplo, aquí vemos un helecho,
un pino, una rosa.
Las tres son plantas vasculares.
Pero, ¿qué las diferencia?
Bueno, el helecho es una planta sin semilla.
El pino y la rosa tienen semillas
pero en el pino las semillas están desnudas
y en la rosa las semillas están encerradas en un ovario.
Siguiendo, aquí vemos tres moluscos:
el pulpo, el calamar y la almeja.
¿Qué los diferencia, además de que la almeja no está
en su ambiente natural sino más bien en el nuestro?
El pulpo y el calamar no tienen caparazón.
La almeja tiene caparazón.
El pulpo no tiene pluma.
Y los que alguna vez cocinaron paella
y limpiaron calamares
saben lo que es la pluma.
Es esa parte cartilaginosa, transparente,
que tienen los calamares adentro.
Aquí vemos el tiburón, el delfín y la orca.
Los tres son hidrodinámicos,
los tres viven en el agua.
Sin embargo, el tiburón...
(los tres son vertebrados)
el tiburón es un pez.
Sus ancestros son peces.
En tanto que el delfín y la orca
son mamíferos que se caracterizan
por dos características de los mamíferos que son:
tener pelos y producir leche.
Ahora, si vemos la diferencia entre el delfín y la orca,
sus ancestros eran cuadrúpedos que vivían en la Tierra
y se parecían a las vacas.
Por lo tanto, esa adaptación a ser hidrodinámicos
es una cosa secundaria.
¿Qué diferencia al delfín de la orca?
El delfín es amigable y la orca "no tanto".
Aquí vemos otras diferencias.
Estos dos individuos pertenecen
a la especie Homo sapiens sapiens.
Magic Johnson tiene piel negra
y Manu Ginóbili, que no va a estar presente
sino que hoy está filmado,
tiene piel blanca.
Ahora, las diferencias también
pueden aplicarse al mundo virtual.
Aquí vemos dos criaturas creadas
por el cineasta James Cameron
que viven en el planeta imaginario Pandora.
Neytiri se diferencia de Jake Sully
en que Neytiri es una navi
y Jake Sully es un avatar.
Ahora bien, la diferencia
es que Jake Sully tiene ADN humano
y, por lo tanto, Jake Sully tiene cinco dedos
y [Neytiri] tiene cuatro dedos.
Y estoy seguro que muchos de los que vieron la película
tendrán ganas de verla de vuelta
para ver si esto que les cuento es cierto.
Sí, es cierto.
Todo esto reside en la molécula
que tiene información genética, que es el ADN.
El ácido desoxirribonucleico.
Yo no tengo tiempo de explicar cómo está codificada
esa información genética en el ADN,
pero sí tengo tiempo de decirles que hay un sin embargo.
Un sin embargo es que todas las características que conté antes
están contenidas en la información del ADN.
Pero hay diferencias entre los seres vivos
que nada tienen que ver con el ADN
sino que tienen que ver con el ambiente.
Por ejemplo, el vicepresidente argentino Julio Cobos
y el expresidente argentino Fernando de la Rúa
pertenecen a la especie Homo sapiens sapiens.
Y hay serias discusiones de ubicarlos en una subespecie,
que es la subespecie dubitativus. (Risas)
Ahora bien, claramente estos dos individuos son muy parecidos
-todos lo sabemos-,
pero los parecidos no son genéticos
sino que son ambientales.
Tienen que ver con su ideología,
con sus deficiencias, con sus virtudes,
con cosas que les sucedieron
durante la experiencia de sus vidas
y probablemente también
por estímulos que recibieron durante
la experiencia de sus vidas intrauterinas.
¿Por qué?
Porque el fenotipo es la suma, digamos, irreversible
del genotipo con el ambiente.
Hay situaciones en las cuales lo genético predomina.
Otras en las cuales lo ambiental predomina.
¿Qué es el fenotipo?
El fenotipo es el aspecto, la morfología,
la fisiología, el comportamiento.
El genotipo "es" el ADN.
Y el ambiente, es eso mismo.
La estructura del ADN es una doble hélice
en la cual hay como letras químicas,
que se llaman bases, que son las que dan las órdenes
para que la célula fabrique proteínas.
La estructura del ADN fue descubierta en 1953
por estos dos científicos famosos:
James Watson y Francis Crick.
Francis Crick se murió en 2004.
Los dos recibieron el Premio Nobel en 1962.
Y James Watson vive.
Vive y este hombre ha sido testigo
en los últimos casi sesenta ańos
de una revolución, no solamente en las ciencias sino,
como vamos a ver ahora, en la industria,
en la vida cotidiana y en la sociedad.
Porque gracias a su descubrimiento
de que la información genética
está contenida en el ADN
se han revolucionado muchos aspectos de nuestra vida.
Aquí lo ven a Crick con una regla de cálculo.
El fotógrafo que tomó esta foto le pidió a Crick
que seńalara la estructura de ADN
en el 53 con una regla de cálculo.
Las personas que están acá y tienen menos de 40 años
he comprobado ayer que no saben lo que es una regla de cálculo.
Yo se las muestro ahí.
Es un instrumento que permitía sacar raíz cuadrada,
obtener logaritmos, multiplicar y dividir
sin necesidad de ningún elemento electrónico.
Es decir, estamos en el 53 en la época
en vez de One Laptop Per Child,
o sea una computadora por niño,
en la época de una regla de cálculo por niño.
No era así porque no se repartían masivamente
las reglas de cálculo, pero quería denotar el componente histórico.
La revolución que Watson presenció
y sigue presenciando
involucra a la medicina y puede haber situaciones
como diagnóstico de enfermedades hereditarias,
infecciosas y cáncer,
remedios producidos por la tecnología de ADN recombinante:
interferón, eritropoyetina, hormona de crecimiento, insulina.
Vacunas recombinantes, como la vacuna contra la hepatitis B
con la que todos Uds. o muchos de Uds. se han vacunado
y está producida por ingeniería genética.
Terapia génica que, si bien no es una realidad cotidiana,
está en una experimentación muy avanzada.
Animales transgénicos.
Medicina personalizada que sí es para el futuro.
Anticuerpos monoclonales que son los que inventó
nuestro Premio Nobel César Milstein.
Y medicina forense, entre los cuales está
la determinación de identidad y lazos familiares.
Yo me voy a detener un minuto en este tema,
porque este tema es específicamente caro a nuestro país.
Justamente el estudio de las diferencias
en las secuencias de ADN y similitudes
ha permitido a nuestro país ser pionero
en la identificación de personas.
En particular, en la identificación
de los hijos de desaparecidos
y en el lazo biológico con sus abuelos.
Alguien ha dicho que el estudio del ADN mitocondrial
parece haber sido ideado para las Abuelas de Plaza de Mayo.
Y ahora quiero hacer una reflexión presente.
Sería importante que el estudio del ADN
se utilice para conocer la verdad en el caso
de los hijos de Ernestina Herrera de Noble.
Porque así como la biología
puede distinguir entre distintas especies,
la biología también puede distinguir entre
un hijo adoptado y un hijo apropiado.
Y esa es una verdad que la Argentina
no puede ocultar nunca más.
(Aplausos)
La revolución también ocurrió
en la industria y en la agricultura.
Hemos tenido y tenemos la industria farmacéutica
del ADN recombinante,
la producción de enzimas de uso industrial,
la detección de contaminación en alimentos,
los animales transgénicos
-en los cuales la Argentina también es pionera-,
tipificación de semen de reproductores,
identificación de ganado robado,
plantas transgénicas que produce nuestro país,
la sojización y, además de la sojización, el superávit fiscal.
Yo me voy a detener un minuto en todos estos ejemplos.
Quizá no todos sepan... Yo me traje un par
de jeans o vaqueros que no están gastados.
Pero cada par de vaqueros gastados
que se vende en todo el mundo hoy en día
ha sido gastado por una enzima
producida por ingeniería genética.
Ya no existe más lo que en inglés
se llama el "stone washing".
No se lavan más los vaqueros
industrialmente con piedras.
Lo que se hace es gastarlos
con una celulasa producida por un hongo.
Los vaqueros son de celulosa;
la celulasa lo degrada. Y ese hongo tiene un gen;
y ese gen ha sido transferido a una bacteria.
La bacteria se cultiva industrialmente
y se produce la enzima
que usan las fábricas de denim
para vender sus vaqueros.
O sea que, miren a qué punto
la revolución de la industria
tecnológica o biotecnológica
afecta nuestra vida cotidiana.
Todo el mundo compra vaqueros gastados.
Bien, en las células se encuentran los cromosomas.
En el cromosoma está el ADN.
El ADN está dividido en segmentos llamados genes.
Cada gen es copiado para fabricar
otro ácido nucleico que se llama ARN.
Y ese ARN a su vez es copiado para fabricar la proteína,
que es el producto final y es el que tiene
la función en nuestras células.
Las proteínas son como los trabajadores,
los laburantes de la célula.
Acá la cosa se pone compleja
y eso tiene que ver con el tema
de trabajo que yo quiero contarles.
Un gen, en realidad, está constituido por segmentos
que se llaman exones y otros segmentos intercalados
que se llaman intrones.
Cuando se copia, se copian los dos
-los exones y los intrones-,
pero antes de que se produzca el copiado dos,
ese ARN que se fabrica, elimina los intrones
-los tira a la basura-
y une los exones entre sí.
Este proceso se llama "splicing",
que en inglés quiere decir "corte y empalme"
y está ocurriendo en sus células en este momento,
simultáneamente, todo el día.
En todos sus genes.
O sea, se fabrica un ARN más largo
que es acortado a uno más corto.
Hasta los años 80, se pensaba que cada gen
era capaz de fabricar una única proteína.
Sin embargo, a mediados de los 80,
se descubrió que un gen es capaz
de fabricar muchas proteínas.
El proceso que lo permite se llama
"splicing alternativo", que es una variante
de lo que les conté recién que se llamaba "splicing".
Y esa variante, que también es complicada,
implica que si el gen tiene exones e intrones,
cuando se copia, en el copiado uno, fabrica esos ARN
que contienen los exones y los intrones
pero luego el splicing
puede ocurrir de dos alternativas distintas.
Por ejemplo, incluyendo al exón que está en el medio
o excluyéndolo, con lo cual el gen
puede fabricar dos proteínas distintas.
Y esto es mucho más complejo porque nuestros genes
pueden fabricar a veces centenares
de proteínas distintas cada uno.
Ahora bien, el splicing alternativo parece ser la causa
de la gran complejidad de los vertebrados.
Es decir, de nosotros.
¿Por qué?
Fíjense. Este gusanito microscópico,
que se llama Caenorhabditis elegans,
es un invertebrado microscópico
de un milímetro de largo
formado por mil células.
Cada una de sus células tiene 19 000 genes.
Hasta acá está bien, esos números no dicen nada.
Pero este otro animal, Madonna,
pertenece a la especie Homo sapiens sapiens.
Es un vertebrado macroscópico,
lo vemos a simple vista,
tiene casi dos metros de altura
y está formado por diez a la trece células.
O sea, por diez billones de células (billones en español)
y tiene 23 000 genes.
Por menos antropocéntricos que queramos ser,
no hay duda de que Madonna
y nosotros somos más complejos
que ese gusanito microscópico miserable.
Sin embargo, el número de genes
que tenemos es similar.
¿En qué radica la diferencia?
Primero, en saber qué no ocurre:
no somos más complejos porque tengamos más genes.
Y, segundo, si bien 19 000
es equivalente a 23 000
en el mismo orden de magnitud,
el gusano con sus 19 000 genes
puede fabricar 25 000 proteínas.
Mientras que nosotros con nuestros 23 000 genes
podemos fabricar casi o más de 100 000 proteínas,
porque el 80% de nuestros genes es capaz de,
por splicing alternativo,
producir más de una proteína.
O sea que nuestra gran complejidad
tiene que ver con la gran cantidad
de variantes de proteínas que podemos hacer.
Cuando digo nuestra me refiero a los vertebrados,
a los mamíferos, a las aves,
no me refiero a nosotros exclusivamente por ser humanos.
Entonces lo que ocurre es que nuestros genes
pueden generar muchas más proteínas que los del gusano.
Ahora, el splicing alternativo
-que es lo que estudiamos en nuestro laboratorio-
tiene mucha importancia
en la causalidad de muchas enfermedades.
Esto simplemente lo doy a título ilustrativo, pero tenemos:
cáncer de mama, renal, gástrico;
enfermedades hereditarias
como el síndrome de frágil X
o la distrofia miotónica,
o la fibrosis quística.
Yo voy a contarles un ejemplo en el cual,
si bien no está comprobado y no es una enfermedad,
el splicing alternativo tiene que ver
con nuestras experiencia cotidianas.
Fíjense. Esto es una oreja.
Adentro hay un aparato sensor, que es el oído.
Si vemos el oído, dentro del oído, en el oído interno,
hay una región que se llama la cóclea.
Y dentro de la cóclea hay un líquido
que vibra cuando llega la onda sonora.
Ese líquido baña unas células
que se llaman células ciliadas.
Y esas células, las cilias, son como pelitos.
Esos pelitos tienen unos canales
que son esos dibujos verdes ahí
que están en su membrana
y que pueden estar cerrados o abiertos.
Y afuera, en el líquido, hay sales, hay iones.
Cuando llega el sonido y hace vibrar el líquido,
estas cilias se mueven mecánicamente.
Y al moverse mecánicamente, abren los canales,
los iones entran y,
como ven abajo donde marca la flecha,
se genera un impulso eléctrico que va al cerebro
y nos hace sentir el sonido.
El problema parece ser que a lo largo
de ese órgano de la cóclea,
las células van captando distintas
frecuencias de sonido.
Nosotros tenemos la capacidad de captar
distintas frecuencias de sonido.
Y, parece ser, se especula,
que cada canal, cada canalito verde
de cada una de las cilias de esas células
es una variante distinta de splicing alternativo.
¿Qué significa esto?
Que la posibilidad de escuchar diversas frecuencias
tiene que ver con una única proteína que es la del canal
-no sé si tiene varios polipétidos, eso es un tema técnico-
pero que, en realidad, las variantes de esa proteína
están adaptadas a captar distintas frecuencias
y a producir impulsos nerviosos
de distinta magnitud respecto de la frecuencia.
Dicho de una manera más simple,
podemos decir que el splicing alternativo
podría significar música para nuestros oídos y poder distinguir,
por ejemplo, cuando escuchamos a Beethoven
o cuando escuchamos a los Beatles.
¿Cómo se regula el splicing alternativo?
En los dos minutos que me quedan voy a resumir,
en dos diapositivas, doce años de trabajo de nuestro laboratorio
acá en la Facultad de Ciencias Exactas y Naturales
de la Universidad de Buenos Aires.
Una de las cosas que vimos es que
si la enzima que copia al gen
para fabricar el ARN es lenta,
eso da posibilidad a que los intrones
se eliminen uno a uno y el resultado
dé un ARN que contiene todos los exones
y dé una de las variantes de splicing alternativo de cada gen.
Sin embargo, si el copiado es rápido,
lo que ocurre es que se elimina
un segmento que contiene al exón de adentro,
no le da oportunidad a cada intrón
de eliminarse individualmente
y eso produce otra variante.
Dicho de otra manera, nosotros encontramos
que la velocidad del copiado
es lo que determina en parte el resultado
de qué variante de proteína produce un dado gen.
Y, recientemente, también encontramos
que esa velocidad del copiado
está muy limitada por la estructura
que adopta el gen en el ADN.
El ADN no está desnudo.
Está asociado a proteínas, formando
lo que se conoce como cromatina.
Y esa cromatina dentro del núcleo
puede estar más relajada o más compacta.
Si está relajada, la enzima que copia lo hace rápido.
Si está compacta, la enzima que copia lo hace lento
como lo muestra el diagrama del camioncito.
No es lo mismo andar sobre una pista de asfalto
que andar sobre el ripio.
Porque en el ripio uno tiene que ir más despacio
porque hay muchas rocas en el camino
que dificultan el paso.
Termino, me faltan 55 segundos,
diciendo que estas dos diapositivas
que reflejan doce años de trabajo
de nuestro grupo de investigación
en el laboratorio se hicieron
en la Faculta de Ciencias Exactas
en el instituto IFIBYNE del CONICET
cuyo director está sentado en el público,
en la Universidad de Buenos Aires.
Y me dijeron que no puedo bajar línea,
pero no puedo contenerme:
la Universidad de Buenos Aires
es una universidad pública, estatal,
gratuita, autónoma, (aplausos)
co-gobernada, laica, masiva,
científica y tecnológica y de excelencia.
(Aplausos)
Tengo un epílogo, pero no lo voy a pasar.
Yo ya terminé. La idea, si TED
es un lugar donde puede haber ideas,
o plantear ideas, la idea que quería
dejar con la última diapositiva
es que es una contraidea.
La contraidea que nos quisieron meter en los 90
de que la educación tenía que ser privatizada,
elitista y recluida a universidades privadas.
Ustedes lo saben, no hace falta
los que me conocen, yo soy un defensor
de la universidad pública.
Pero no es un capricho.
Es que la experiencia cotidiana indica
que la universidad pública,
y en esas condiciones que mencioné,
es el lugar natural donde se genera el conocimiento.
Que la universidad privada puede aspirar
a generar conocimiento, pero no lo logra.
No lo logra porque le faltan
un montón de esos factores
que están allí.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)